[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
NANCY KANWISHER: We are turning
from our various other topics
to talk about hearing today.
And let's start by thinking
about all the cool stuff
that you can do
just by listening.
So just by listening, you
can identify the scene
that you're in and
what's going on
in it, like for example, this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so you know what kind of
room you're in and roughly
what's going on, just from
that little bit of sound.
You can localize events
and people and objects.
So close your eyes, everyone.
Keep them closed.
And if you just
listen to me talking,
it's really very
vivid, isn't it,
exactly how obvious
it is where I am.
And I will refrain
from the temptation
of coming up and speaking
in somebody's ears
because it's just too creepy.
OK, you can open your eyes.
It's very vivid.
Just from listening, you know
where the sound source is.
You can recognize sound
sources, so for example,
sounds like this--
[GLASS BREAKING]
You know what happened there.
It's a whole vivid event
just unfolded there
in a whole second and a
half, or a random series
of sounds like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- It's supposed to
either rain or snow.
[RANDOM SOUNDS]
- Hannah is good
at compromising.
[RANDOM SOUNDS]
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: Anyway,
every one of those
sounds you
immediately recognize.
You know exactly what it is.
And that's environmental
sounds, things
that happen outdoors,
speech, what is being said,
voices, who is saying it.
If you don't know the person,
if they're male or female,
young or old, much like faces--
if you know them, you'll
recognize them pretty fast.
You can selectively attend
to one sound among others.
Like if you had a little, hidden
earphone that I didn't see,
and you wanted to listen
to your favorite podcast,
you could listen to
that occasionally when
I was getting boring.
And then you could turn
back and listen to me.
And you could just
selectively choose
which of those different
audio inputs to listen to.
And we'll talk more in a moment
about this classic problem
in hearing, which is known as
the "cocktail party effect."
I guess it was named in the '50s
when cocktail parties were big.
And it consists in
the fact that when
there are multiple sound
sources, such as many people
talking in a room, you
can tune in one channel
and then tune in
another channel.
And you can just
selectively attend
to one of many
sound sources, even
though those sound sources are
massively overlapping on top
of each other in the input.
And it's a big
computational challenge,
as we'll talk about
shortly, to do that.
You can enjoy music.
And you can determine
what things are made of.
So close your eyes and I'm going
to drop things on the table.
Don't look.
I'm going to do various
things and you're
going to identify them.
So let's see-- don't
open your eyes.
See if you can tell what's
being dropped on the table,
or at least what it's made of.
Close your eyes.
That's cheating.
Wood, exactly.
Very good.
OK, what is this?
Keep your eyes closed.
What is this made of?
- Plastic.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, good.
Keep your eyes closed.
What is this made of?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
OK, keep your eyes closed.
What's this made of?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER: Awesome.
OK, you can open your eyes.
Perfect.
You guys are awesome.
I just dropped these objects
that I found from my kitchen
this morning and you guys could
tell what they're made of.
That's amazing.
OK, all of this that
you guys just did
happens from the
simplest possible signal.
We'll talk about what that
signal is exactly in a moment,
but it's just sound compression
coming through the air.
And it tells you all this rich
stuff about your environment.
So the question is,
how do we do that?
And the first
question is, how do we
start to think about
how hearing works, how
you're able to do all of that?
And you guys know we start
with computational theory--
considering what the inputs
are, what the outputs are,
the physics of sound,
what would be involved
if we tried to code up a machine
to take those audio input
and deliver the output
that you guys all
just delivered with
no trouble whatsoever.
What cues are in the stimulus?
What are the key
computational challenges?
And what makes those aspects
of hearing challenging?
And then after we
do all that stuff
at the level of
computational theory,
we can, of course, study
hearing in other ways,
like studying it behaviorally.
What can people do and not do?
What's hard?
What's less hard?
And we can measure
neural responses.
So we'll talk about all of that.
But let's start with a
little more on what sound is.
So sound is just a
single univariate signal
coming into the ears.
We'll say more about
that in a second,
but it's really, really simple.
And from that, you get
all this rich experience.
And so the question
is, what goes
on in that magic
box in the middle
to enable you to extract
this kind of information
from this really simple signal?
So let's start
with what is sound.
Sound is just a set of
longitudinal compressions
and decompressions of the
air coming from the source
into your ear.
So these waves travel
from the source
to the ear in little
waves of compression
where the air is
just compressed,
and rarefaction where
the air is spread out.
And just to give you a sense
of how physical sound is,
there's a silly video here.
It's a speaker in a sink
with a bunch of paint.
And you can just see that
the movement of the speaker--
normally, it makes those
compressions and rarefactions
of air, but if you
stick paint on it.
It's going to shove the
paint up in the air,
too, just to show you
how physical it is.
There's something called
Schlieren photography,
which is totally cool, and which
is a way to visualize those
compressions of the air
to show you what's--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- --use it to study
aerodynamic flow.
And sound-- well, that's just
another change in air density,
a traveling compression wave.
So Schlieren visualization,
along with a high-speed camera,
can be used to see it as well.
Here's a book
landing on a table,
the end of a towel
being snapped,
a firecracker, an AK-47,
and of course, a clap.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, so
just compressions of air
traveling from the source to
your ears-- that's all it is.
So natural sounds happen at
lots of different frequencies.
And one of the ways
we describe sounds
is by looking at
those frequencies.
So there's an awesome website
that is here on your slides.
You can play with it offline.
But meanwhile, we're going to
play with it a little bit right
now because it is so cool.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to look at spectrograms
of different sounds.
Let's start with a
person whistling.
[WHISTLING]
OK, so frequency
is on this axis,
higher frequencies up here,
lower frequencies there.
And it's going by in time.
[WHISTLING]
So whistling is unusual
in that it's pretty much
a single frequency at a time.
Many natural sounds
are not like that.
So you see not single,
but a small, narrow band
of frequencies at a time.
OK, that's enough.
[WHISTLING]
Stop.
All right.
OK.
[TROMBONE PLAYING]
OK, so you see how
with the trombone,
there were many different
bands of frequencies.
In contrast-- this is
me talking, by the way.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
But with the whistling, you saw
just a single band at a time.
With the trombone, it has
all of these harmonics,
these parallel lines of
multiples of frequencies.
Those are called
"pitched sounds."
Sounds that have a pitch where
you could sing back the tune
have those bands of
frequencies like that.
And so that's what you
see with the trombone.
You see a little bit of this
with natural speech here.
You can see sets of
bands, but mostly, you
see vertical stripes.
That's because I'm talking fast
and mostly what's coming out
is consonants.
If I slowed down and
stretched out the vowels,
you would see more
of those harmonics.
Fun and games.
OK, so that's what
sound looks like.
So everybody has to
have a sense of this
is showing you the energy
at each frequency over time
in response to natural speech.
We'll play with this a little
bit more later in the lecture.
So we did all that.
We'll do some of that
other stuff later.
So now that we have some
sense of what sound is
and what that input
is, how are we
going to think about how to
extract information from it?
What we want to do is
think about how is it?
Why is it challenging to
get to that from this?
There are several reasons
that's challenging.
First is invariance
problems, much like we've
discussed in the domain of
vision and other domains
already in this class.
And so the way to think about
that here is that a given sound
source sounds really different
in different situations.
So if we have different
people saying the same word,
that will look very different
on those spectrograms.
The stimulus is
actually different,
even though we want to just
know what word is being said.
And conversely, if we
have the same person
saying two different words,
that will look really different.
And even if we want to
know just who's speaking,
we have to deal with the
invariance of generalizing
across those very different
ways, very different
sounds that they produce when
they say different things.
So those are kind of
flips of each other.
To recognize voices, we
want invariance of the voice
with respect to the words.
To recognize words, we want
invariance for the words
independent of the voice.
And those are all
tied up together.
So we need to appreciate the
sameness of those stimuli
across those changes.
Here's another reason that
hearing is challenging--
I mentioned this briefly--
in normal situations-- it's
pretty quiet in the room.
There's some background
noise, but not
a whole lot of other
noise, so it's mostly
just me making
the noise in here.
But in many situations, there
are multiple sound sources.
For example, listen to this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- All right, Debbie
Whittaker, Sterling James,
wrapping things up.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, little
segment of radio, there's
music, and a person
speaking both at once.
And you had no
problem hearing what
the person was
saying and knowing
something about the gender
and age of that person.
You recognize the voice,
the content of the speech,
even though the music
is right on top of it.
So the music might be like
this and the speech like that.
And what you hear is
this, with those things
right on top of each other.
So you need to go backwards
to hear these things,
even though that's all you get.
Everybody see how
that's a big challenge?
If you had to write the code
to take this and recover
that, best of luck to you.
Yeah, question?
STUDENT: How does intensity or
volume come into this picture
again?
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
not really well depicted
on these diagrams.
This is just showing
you the entire source.
So the intensity I showed before
essentially takes this and does
a Fourier analysis of it so that
it gives you the energy at each
of those frequencies.
So you could just do a
Fourier analysis on this
and you get a spectrogram.
So the listener's
usually interested
in individual sources
even though they're
superimposed on other sources.
And that's a real problem.
So this is the input.
They get added together, and the
brain has to pull them apart.
So this is a classic,
ill-posed problem.
That means just given
this, we have no way
to go backwards to that
if that's all we have,
because there's multiple
possible solutions.
It's like saying,
"x plus y equals 9,
now solve for x and y."
And whenever we're
in that situation
of an ill-posed problem with
multiple possible solutions,
only one of which is right in
any situation in the world,
the usual answer is
that we need to bring
in some other assumptions or
world knowledge or something,
to constrain that problem and
narrow that large, usually
infinite, space of
possible answers
down to the one correct one.
So this is a classic
problem that people
have talked about in
audition for many decades.
Josh McDermott in this
department does a lot of work
on it.
And you can solve it
in part by knowledge
of natural sounds, which I
won't talk about in detail here.
One more challenge for
solving problems in audition
comes from the fact
that real world
sounds, including the sound
of my voice right now,
have reverb.
So "reverb" means--
this is an aerial view.
That's a person, kind of hard
to see in an aerial view.
And that's a sound source.
And some of the sound comes
straight from the sound source
to the person's ears.
But a lot of the sound goes
and ricochets off the walls,
god knows how many times,
before it hits the ears.
And all of those
different paths of sound
are all kind of
superimposed at the ears.
And they arrive at
different times,
making a hell of a mess
of the input sound.
So instead of that nice,
clean, straightforward input,
you have the input plus
a slightly delayed input,
a more delayed input, another
delayed input, all superimposed
on top of each other.
That's reverb.
Is that clear, what
the problem is?
So now we have this
really messed-up signal
that we're trying to go
backwards and understand
what the input is.
So I'll give you an example.
This is a recording of
what's known as "dry speech."
That means speech
with no reverb.
Sorry, question?
STUDENT: I'm just having a
little trouble understanding
why reverb poses a problem.
The stimulus isn't changing,
it's just delayed over time.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, OK.
Let's do a vision example.
This is a little crazy,
but let me just try this.
Suppose we had a
photograph of my face
and you have to recognize it.
OK, fine.
Various visual
algorithms can do that.
But now suppose we took that
photograph and we moved it
over 10%, and we superimposed
it and added them together,
and then we moved it over
again and added them together,
and moved it over again
and add them together.
Pretty soon you
have a blurry mess.
And those things are all
on top of each other,
just as two people talking at
once are on top of each other.
And so you have a real
problem going backwards.
Does that make sense?
OK.
OK, so here's dry
speech with no reverb.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- They ate the lemon pie.
Father forgot the bread.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
here's the same speech
but with lots of reverb.
- They ate the lemon pie.
Father forgot the bread.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
now you can still
hear it because your
auditory system knows
how to solve this problem.
But look what happens
to the spectrogram.
Here-- this is time this
way, frequency this way,
and the dark bits are where the
energy is, where the power is.
In the dry speech, you see all
these nice, vertical things,
and here you see a blurry mess.
Nonetheless, you
can hear it fine.
And further, what else could
you tell from the reverb?
STUDENT: The size of the room.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, it's in
a cathedral or something, right?
So it's not just that
it causes a problem.
Reverb also tells us
something about the location
we're in, if we know
how to extract it,
which you guys' visual--
auditory systems do.
You can see I'm a
vision scientist.
So how to study this?
There's a very beautiful
paper that Josh McDermott
published a few years ago.
And I'm going to try to give
you the gist of the paper
without all the
technical details,
because I think
it's just brilliant.
So they wanted to characterize
what exactly is reverb.
And reverb is going to
vary for different sounds.
You heard the reverb in
that cathedral-like space.
That's very different from
the reverb in this room, which
also happens.
It's harder to hear
because it's less obvious.
But you can tell a
lot about the space
you're in because the reverb
properties are different.
The distance to the
walls are different.
The reflective
properties are different.
And so there's
information there.
So you can characterize the
nature of the reverb in any one
location by making an
instantaneous, brief click
sound in that environment
and recording what
happens after that.
And then you can collect all
the reverberant reflections
of that sound off the walls.
So what they did
is they went around
to lots of natural locations and
they played a click like this.
[CLICK]
That's it, just a click.
And then they recorded.
So this is the initial
click, but this
is what you record in a single
location, all this stuff.
And those are all the
reverberant reflections
of that sound off the
walls-- make sense?
For one location.
So then they did that in a
whole bunch of locations.
And the idea is that
here is a description
of the basic problems, just
the same thing I said before,
but slightly more detailed.
So a sound source would
be something like this.
This looks like a
person speaking,
with those nice, harmonic,
parallel bands, like you
saw when I was speaking.
Maybe it's a trombone.
So that's time.
That's the source.
That's what you want to know.
This is now the impulse
response function
for the location where
that sound is being played,
determined by doing that
click and recording.
I showed you just
you do a Fourier
analysis of that black
curve in the previous slide
and you get something like this.
And that shows you all
the echoes that happen
in that sound in that location.
And there are
different time delays,
and different intensities,
and frequency dependence.
What comes to your ear is
basically this times that.
So you're given
this and you have
to go backwards
and solve for that.
Everybody see the problem?
So what McDermott and
Traer showed is that--
just to state the problem
a little more clearly--
you're interested in the
source and/or the environment.
You might want to
know what kind of room
am I, if somebody is dragging
you around blindfolded.
You might want to know if
you're outside, or inside,
or in a cathedral,
or a closet, or what.
And now this should seem
very analogous to the problem
of color vision.
Remember the problem
of color vision?
We want to know the color
of this object right here.
So this little,
purple patch here,
we want to know that, but all
we have is the light coming
to our eyes from that patch.
And the light coming to
our eyes from the patch
is a function not just of
the property of the object,
but whatever light happens
to be coming onto it
and then reflecting to our eyes.
And so in color
vision, we have one set
of tricks to try to
solve that problem
and recover the actual
properties of the object,
even though it's totally
confounded in the input
with the properties
of the incident light.
This is extremely analogous.
We're trying to solve for
what is the sound source.
And we have to deal
with this problem that
is completely confounded with
the reverberation of the room
it's in.
Does everybody see that analogy?
They're both classic ill-posed
problems in perception.
So here's another way of
putting it-- we're given that
and we want to solve
for at least one
of these, ideally both of those.
And you can't do
that with just this.
So we need to make
assumptions about the room.
And what Traer and
McDermott showed
is that first, they measured
those impulse response
functions in
natural environments
to characterize reverb in
different environments.
And they found that there's some
systematic properties of reverb
having to do with
the decay function
as a function of frequency.
And those systematic
properties are preserved
across different environments.
And then they showed that
your auditory system knows
about the way reverb
works, in the sense
that if you make up a different,
non-physical reverb property
and you play it to people,
it sounds weird, number one.
And two, they can't
recover the sound source.
And what that means is, built
into your auditory system
is knowledge of the
physics of sound,
and in particular about the
particulars of the decay
function of reverb,
such that you
can use that knowledge
of how reverb
works in general to
undo this problem,
and constrain this problem,
and solve for the sound source.
I didn't give you
all the details.
But I want you to get the gist.
Do you get the kind of idea?
OK.
But as I said, that's
only true for reverb
that has the reverb properties
of real-world sound.
If you make up fake
reverb, it doesn't work.
And people can't
solve this problem.
That tells you they're
using their knowledge.
Doesn't tell us whether that
knowledge is built in innately,
or whether they
learned it, or what.
All right, good.
So in other words, we
solve the ill-posed problem
of recovering the sound
source despite reverb
by building a knowledge of
the physics of the world
into our auditory
system and using
it to constrain the problem.
So we just said, why is this
computationally challenging?
Invariance problems,
appreciating the sameness
of a voice across
different words,
appreciating the sameness of a
word across different voices.
Separating multiple
sound sources that come
in simultaneously and are
just massively superimposed
on the input-- the cocktail
party problem, also ill-posed--
and the reverb problem.
So everybody see how these are
three really big challenges
for audition?
Yeah.
STUDENT: So was brain imaging as
well a part of the [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Nope.
One could do that
and ask questions
about where that's
solved in the brain.
But the beauty of
that study is that
in a way, who cares
where it's solved?
I mean, it's kind
of interesting,
but it's such a beautiful story
already just from actually,
a big part of their study
was measuring reverb.
Nobody had done it before.
They sent people
out with speakers,
and recording devices,
and little random timers
on their iPhones.
And at random times--
how did this go--
oh, yeah, they had
people had to mark the location
they were in using their iPhone
GPS and then that's right--
they didn't send people out
with recording devices.
It's too hard.
And so then they sampled
what kind of places
do people hang out in.
And then they went back
with their impulse sound
source and the recording
device, and they
measured that impulse
response function
in lots and lots of
different natural sounds
in order to characterize
what is the nature of reverb
in the world.
Nobody had done that before.
So that's why I tell you
this, is that to me, it's
just one of the most
beautiful examples
of computational theory--
no measurement in the brain.
A big part of the study
was just characterizing
the physics of
sound, and then some
psychophysics to say
actually, do people
use that knowledge of how
reverb works in the world?
And yes, they do.
So I've been talking
about hearing in general,
but let's talk about one of
the most interesting examples
of hearing, the one you're doing
right now-- speech perception.
So what do speech
sounds look like?
You saw a few of
them briefly before.
Here are a few spectra.
So just to remind you,
each one of these things
has time going along the
x-axis, frequency here.
And the color shows you
the intensity of energy
at that frequency band.
So this is a person saying,
"hot," and "hat," and "hit,"
and "head."
That's the same person saying
these four things, a person
with a high-pitched voice.
And here's a person with a
slightly lower-pitched voice
saying the same things.
So what do we notice here?
Well, first of all, we see
that vowels have regularly
spaced harmonics.
That's the red stripes.
This is a vowel
sound right there.
See those perfectly
regularly spaced harmonics?
That makes a pitchy sound,
so voices are pitchy.
You may not think that
there's a pitch to my voice
right now because I'm
talking, not singing,
but there is a pitch.
And you use that,
actually, in the intonation
of speech, as you guys
read about in the assigned
reading for yesterday.
So each of these things
with the stacked harmonics
is a vowel sound.
It's got a pitch and it
lasts over a chunk of time.
And the consonants are
these kind of muckier things
that happen before and after.
And consonants don't have pitch.
They don't have harmonics.
They have kind of muck.
So there are certain
band-- people
who study speech spend a lot
of time staring at these things
and characterizing them.
And they like to talk about
bands of frequency, of power.
And so this band
down here that's
present in all of
these speech sounds
here is called a "formant."
It's just a chunk of
the frequency spectrum
that you hear with speech.
So that's a formant.
And some of those
frequency bands or formants
are particularly diagnostic
for different vowels.
So if you look in
this range here,
only in that mid-range
here, only for "hat"
and a little bit
for "F" sound do
you get an energy in
that frequency band,
not for "hot" or "hit."
And that's true both for
the high-pitched voice
and the low-pitched voice.
This frequency band here is
really diagnostic to which
of those vowels you're hearing.
So we're going to play
with that spectrogram
again a little bit
more, although I now
have learned avoidance.
So this is me speaking
again, as you saw before.
So I'm going to say
an A, an E, an I--
look how different
that one is, O, and U.
And there's lots
of other vowels.
Do you see how that
energy moves around
for the different vowels?
Now as I said before, if I
do a long vowel like this,
it makes a big, long
bunch of harmonics.
But a lot of the time, they're
just these vertical lines.
The vertical lines are
consonants, t, p, k, r.
If I don't say a vowel, you
just see a vertical line.
It's not quite a vertical line.
They are different from each
other in ways you can tell.
So the consonants are
those bands of energy
that go vertically.
And the vowels are the big,
long harmonic structures
that stretch between them.
Now, I'm not sure you'll
be able to do this.
I'm going to need a volunteer
in a second, and I'm
going to pick on
[? Iadun, ?] because he's
most accessible right there.
So come on up here.
You know it won't be
horrible or embarrassing.
So you can stand
here for a second.
I'm going to say "ba's" and
"pa's" and I'll tell you
in a moment what to say.
I'm not sure this
is going to work.
I tried it before.
We're going to look at
two different formants
when I say "ba."
Actually, I'm going to do
it rising-- ba, pa, ba, pa.
So there's two different
formants, here and here,
with both of those.
I'm going to do it again.
And there's just a
tiny, little difference
between a ba and a pa.
And it has to do with the
interval between the consonant,
which is the first
vertical thing,
and the vowel, which is
the horizontal stuff.
So let's see if we
can see it again.
Here we go.
Ba, pa-- do you see how
the pa starts earlier there
and the ba is slightly delayed?
I'll show you diagrams
that show you more clearly.
OK, great.
Don't go away.
So we're going to do
the cocktail party
thing with the
recording devices here.
What is this?
This is just some boring
administrative thing
you can just read.
I actually brought it to crumple
and make a crumpling sound,
but we'll do that afterwards.
Right now, you
will read from that
and I will recite
something boring.
And we'll just do
it simultaneously.
So just focus on
what you're doing.
And everybody watch.
You can see my voice here.
And let's see what happens when
we're both talking at once.
OK, here we go.
Four score and seven years ago--
oh, geez, I forget how it
goes after that, so I'll just
have to make up some
other random garbage.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STUDENT: --outstanding--
NANCY KANWISHER: OK.
STUDENT: --review the
student's course--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NANCY KANWISHER: That's great.
That's great.
Don't go away.
I don't know if you could
tell that it got muckier
when we were both talking.
Maybe it's mucky enough with
me talking fast to begin with.
Let's try a few other things.
Let's have me say words
and you say words.
And let's see how
different they look.
OK, so I'm going
to say "mousetrap."
STUDENT: Mousetrap.
NANCY KANWISHER: You can
see some similarity there,
can't you?
Let's do it again.
Mousetrap.
STUDENT: Mousetrap.
NANCY KANWISHER:
OK, that's good.
It's funny, I see more
low-frequency band here.
I'm sure your voice
is lower than mine.
Pitch, interestingly, isn't just
about how low the energy goes.
It's an interesting,
complicated property
of the lowest common denominator
of that whole frequency stack.
So I'm not going to do pitch.
It's complicated.
What else do we want to do?
Let's try some ba's and pa's.
But let's stick them
on the fronts of words.
Maybe that'll work better--
pat, bat.
STUDENT: Pat, bat.
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, I could
see the commonality there.
Could you guys see that?
Let's do it again.
Pat, bat.
STUDENT: Pat, bat.
NANCY KANWISHER: Well,
yours look more similar.
All right.
Anyway, thank you.
That's good.
That's all I need, just to
show you how hard this is,
and how there's variability
across speakers saying
the same thing, and very,
very subtle differences
between sounds that sound
totally different to us.
So back to lecture.
So you saw the harmonics, those
red stripes, during the vowels.
You noticed that I
showed the consonants
and the ba's and pa's.
So here's a diagram.
I'm sorry, this
is very abstracted
away from those
spectrograms, which
are messy, as you can see.
The idea is that a consonant
vowel sound, a single syllable
like ba or pa--
this is time this way-- has
this big, long formant which
is a band of energy that's
the vowel, the ah sound.
And it's these transitions
that happen just before
that that make the difference
for different consonants.
And in particular,
the difference
between a ba and a pa--
this is a ba, that's a pa--
the difference we were looking
for that didn't show up that
clearly, but you
can try it at home,
maybe you can get it clearer
than I just got it now--
has to do with that transition
onto the first formant.
So with a ba, the transitions
happen in parallel.
And with a pa, this
transition happens
before that lower formant.
So that tiny, little--
it's a 65 millisecond delay
in the case of pa that you
don't have in the case of ba,
is how you tell that difference.
It's very, very subtle.
So there's lots of
different kinds of phonemes.
We've been talking about
vowels and consonants.
Each vowel or consonant
sound is called a "phoneme"
if a distinction
in that sound makes
the difference between
two different words
in your language.
And that means that what counts
as a phoneme in one language
may not be a phoneme
in another language,
because it won't
make a distinction
between different words.
Many of the phonemes are shared
across languages, but not all.
We've talked about R and L that
aren't distinguished in Japan,
and two different
D sounds that sound
the same to me that are
distinguished in Hindi,
and lots of others.
And so those are just variations
across natural languages
on which of those phonemes,
which of those sounds,
are used to discriminate
different words,
and hence count as
phonemes in that language.
So there's some particularly
awesome phonemes
that use a particular
kind of consonant
known as a click consonant.
And these are common in some
Southern African languages.
And a year ago, I was traveling
in Mozambique, which was just
hit by a devastating flood.
It's really awful.
But anyway, I was there
visiting a game park
seeing all kinds of animals.
And I met this guy, Test.
And he's amazing.
I mean, his knowledge
of the natural history
was mind blowing,
but he also speaks,
I think, six different
languages fluently, one of which
is Xhosa, or as he would say,
[SPEAKING Xhosa] or something
like that.
You'll hear him
say it in a moment.
And so he was illustrating
click languages.
And I'll play this
for you in a second.
And he says there's a
sentence in Xhosa which
is a little bit crazy, but
has all the different clicks.
And it means, basically,
"the skunk was rolling
and accidentally got
cut by the throat."
Doesn't mean a whole
lot, but listen
to Test saying the
sentence, first in English
and then in Xhosa.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The phrase in
English, it says skunk
was rolling and accidentally
got cut by the throat.
In Xhosa, or in east
Xhosa, [SPEAKING Xhosa].
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER:
Isn't that awesome?
I think we just have to
crank it up a little bit
and hear him again.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- The phrase in English, it
says the skunk was rolling
and accidentally get
cut by the throat.
In Xhosa or in east
Xhosa, [SPEAKING Xhosa].
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK,
for the most part,
we don't have click
consonants in English
that count as
phonemes in the sense
of distinguishing
different words.
But we do have click consonants
that we use in other domains.
Anybody know what we use
click consonants for?
There's at least two.
Know any click consonants?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] That's--
NANCY KANWISHER: Like what?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes, but
that's a regular consonant.
It's actually not a click.
It's just a regular consonant.
Well, one is when you go, tsk,
tsk, tsk, the scolding sound.
It's not a phoneme.
It's not a word, but it has
a very particular meaning.
Another one is how you get a
horse to giddy up. (CLICKS)
So those are the click
consonants we have in English.
They're not phonemes,
but we have them,
and he's got a whole lot more.
That was just for fun.
So why is speech
perception challenging?
Well, one is the essence of
it is that a given speech
sound is highly variable.
One way it's
variable is that when
you speak at different
rates, all the frequencies
go up and down and
haywire, making
them very different across
different talking rates.
Another is the context.
So a given phoneme, like a
ba, or a pa sound, or a vowel,
sounds totally different
depending on what phonemes
come before and after it.
They're not little punctate,
one at a time things.
They all overlap and affect
each other in a big mess.
And the third is one
we've already mentioned,
which is the big
differences across speakers
in the language.
So you have to
recognize a ba sound
even though it sounds
quite different when
spoken by different speakers.
So all of these things make
it very computationally
challenging to
understand speech.
Here's an illustration of
that talker variability.
So what's shown here is not
a whole spectrogram, but just
the intensity of
the first formant
and the second formant,
those bands of energy
that I showed you
in the spectrogram.
And so each dot here
is a different person
pronouncing a vowel.
And each color-- this is
one vowel here in green,
in that green ellipse, with
lots of different people
saying that vowel.
Here's another vowel
up here in red,
with lots of different
people saying that vowel.
And what you see is
they're really overlapping.
So that means you can't just
go from the energy at those two
formants, a point in that space,
and know what the vowel is.
What if you were right there?
Well, then it could be any
of four different vowels.
So that's the problem of
talker variability illustrated
with vowels.
Does that make sense?
I think I just said all of
this, blah, blah, blah--
another classic ill-posed
problem in perception.
You're given a
point in this space.
How do you tell
which vowel it is?
So one way we solve that is that
we learn each other's voices.
And we know how a
given person pronounces
a given set of vowels or words.
And we use that to constrain
what they're saying.
Have you ever
noticed, especially
if you meet somebody new--
well, actually, you just
experience this with Test.
When he first speaks,
his English is beautiful,
but he's from Zimbabwe and
he has kind of Zimbabwe,
British-type accent.
And at first it's hard to
understand what he's saying.
Did you all experience
that briefly?
I mean, that's why I put
the text on the slide,
so you would get used to his
English and understand it.
If I hadn't, you probably
wouldn't have understood
that sentence he spoke first.
That's because we don't
know his voice yet.
But did you notice, after
even just a few words,
you start to like tune right
in and you can understand him?
So learning about an
individual's voice
helps you pull apart the
properties of the voice,
and unconfound
them from the sound
so you can understand what
that person is saying.
So that's part of how we
solve this ill-posed problem.
And so evidence
that we do that is
that if you have people listen
to voices they don't know
or voices that are
changing from word to word,
it's much harder to
understand speech.
So you imagine you took the
sentence I'm saying right now,
and you spliced in a different
person saying each word.
Actually, I should
make that demo.
One of you guys
send me an email--
make that demo of a
different person speaking
each word in a sentence.
It'd be really
hard to understand.
Because you wouldn't
have been able to fix
this was a property
of the voice,
now we can kind of separate
that from everything else.
Because the damn voice will
be changing on each word.
It'll be a mess.
So that's one problem.
So it turns out that the
opposite is true, as well.
And that is, your ability to
recognize somebody's voice
is a function of what you
know about that language.
So you can recognize
voices better in a language
you know than a language
you don't because you're
doing the opposite.
You're using knowledge of
the language and its speech
properties that you
already know to constrain
the problem of figuring out
who is this person's voice.
So does everybody get this?
These two things are affecting
each other-- the speaker
and what's being said.
And because they're
so confounded,
massively confounded
in the stimulus,
to solve that, the more
you know about the speaker,
the better you can
understand what's being said.
And the more you know about the
language and its properties,
the more you can
recognize the voice.
Each one is a source of
information about one
of those two
confounded variables.
And so people have shown
that psychophysically.
And I think I have
time to do this.
Here's a kind of cool
corollary of this,
and that is, it's commonly
thought that dyslexia is most
fundamentally a problem of
auditory speech perception, not
a visual problem.
There may also be a bit
of a visual problem,
but it's thought
that at core, it's
a problem of auditory
speech perception.
So if that's true,
then you might
think that this ability to
use knowledge of the language
and its sounds to
constrain voice recognition
would be reduced in
people with dyslexia,
because they are less good
at processing speech sounds.
And it turns out that's true.
So here's a beautiful study from
Gabrielli Lab a few years ago.
So first look at
the bars in blue.
So this is accuracy
at voice recognition,
which person is speaking.
And this is native
English speakers
who don't speak Chinese.
They are much more
accurate recognizing
who's speaking when they're
speaking English than when
they're speaking Chinese.
So that's kind of cool.
That shows you the
way in which you
use knowledge of the language
to constrain recognition
of the voice.
But now look what happens
in the dyslexics--
no effect, exactly
as they predicted.
Given that the dyslexics have a
problem with speech perception,
they're apparently
not able to use
that knowledge of the
phonemes of the language
to constrain the problem
of voice recognition.
They're just as bad
at voice recognition--
I'm sorry, they're no
better at voice recognition
in their native language
than in a foreign language.
They can't use that knowledge
to constrain voice recognition.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, I love that study.
So we haven't done any
brain stuff so far.
We were just thinking about the
problem of hearing and speech
perception, and what
we know from behavior.
And we've learned a
lot already, but we'll
learn more by looking at
the brain, and the meat,
and all of that.
So let's start with the ear.
Again, remember, compressions
of air come into the ear.
They travel through
the ear canal.
They hit the tympanic membrane.
They go through a whole series
of transducers, these three
little ear bones
here that connect
to this snail-shaped thing,
which is called the "cochlea."
Cochlea is really important.
You should remember that word.
It's the place where you
transduce incoming sound
into neural impulses,
way in there.
And the cochlea is really cool.
It's this, as I said,
a snail-shaped thing.
And there are nerve endings
all the way along this thing.
And because of the
physics of the cochlea,
there are different resonant
frequencies at different parts
of this snail.
So basically, here are some
low-frequency sound waves.
This is the cochlea stretched
out with the base and the apex.
This is the base.
That's the apex.
And what you see is
the low frequencies
have transduced some energy
at the base of the cochlea,
and also at the apex.
But midway range frequencies
and high frequencies
do nothing at the apex.
This business, there's
only physical fluctuations
happening up here for
low frequency sounds.
So there's little
nerve endings here
that detect those
fluctuations up there
and send those signals
up into the brain
through the auditory nerve.
And so in the middle,
here or something,
you have sensitivity to
mid-range frequencies,
not high or low.
And at the base, it's sensitive
more to high frequencies
than mid or low.
So everybody get that?
So basically, the cochlea
is doing a Fourier transform
on the acoustic signal.
It's taking these compressions
of air, and it's just saying,
let's separate those out
into different frequencies,
just with this physical device.
It's like a physical Fourier
transform that's saying,
let's just physically
separate the energy
at each frequency range along
the length of the cochlea.
Does that make sense?
And then once you get different
parts of the cochlea that
are sensitive to different
frequencies oscillating
to different degrees, then you
stick some nerve cells there
to pick up those oscillations,
go up the auditory nerve,
and travel into the brain.
Everybody have a gist
of how this works?
So that's cool.
But now, let's go
up to the brain.
So now, this is
a view like this.
And so here are the cochleae--
I guess that's the plural--
on each side-- ears,
ear canal, cochleae.
And the first thing to
know, which is important,
is that the path between the
cochlea and the first step
up in the cortex is much
more complicated in hearing
than it is in vision.
Look at all these
nuclei deep down
in the basement of the brain.
In contrast, in vision,
how many synapses
do you have to make
between the retina
and primary visual cortex?
Sorry.
One synapse.
Right?
STUDENT: Well, I was thinking--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, two, that's
right, so retinal ganglion
cells send their axons straight
into the LGN in the
thalamus, make a synapse.
And then those LGN
neurons go straight
up to primary visual cortex,
just one stop on the way.
Look at all the stops
on the way here.
So audition is a
really different beast
from hearing in many ways.
Next time, we'll talk
about how audition--
not these parts of it, but
after you get up to the cortex--
audition, we in my lab
and a few other labs
are really starting
to suspect, is
profoundly different in humans
from any non-human animal.
And I think that's for
very interesting reasons,
but this part is pretty
similar in animals,
just getting information
up to the cortex.
And audition is already very
different from vision just
in the number of relays
going up to the brain.
So those structures down there
do all kinds of awesome things.
And last year, I
talked at great length
about how we detect the
locations of sounds.
It's absolutely beautiful
work, and elegant, and fun,
but I decided that was a
little too much behavior.
We should get on to the brain.
But I recommend 9.35 if you want
to learn more about audition--
awesome course.
Did you take it?
Really awesome course.
Yeah, exactly.
And so you'll learn more
about all that stuff.
So instead, we will
just skip all that
and go straight up to cortex.
So the first place that
auditory information
hits the cortex coming
up from the cochleae
is primary auditory cortex,
just like the first place
visual information hits the
cortex coming up from the eyes
is primary visual cortex.
So you can see in here that in a
cross-sectional view like that,
this is primary auditory cortex.
It's in that sulcus right there.
That's kind of a
drag, because when
we get occasional
opportunities to test patients
who have grids of electrodes
on the surface of their brain,
the grids don't
usually go in there
and we can't see
primary auditory cortex.
Although there are
new methods where
they stick depth
electrodes, which
is surprisingly, apparently,
better on the patients.
And right now your TA,
Dana [? Bobinger, ?]
is over at Children's Hospital
recording from a 19-year-old
who has bad epilepsy and who has
depth electrodes in his brain.
And he's listening to
all kinds of sounds.
And she's recorded his neural
activity with depth electrodes.
And so we are
hopeful, one, that we
can find some
information that will be
relevant to the neurosurgeons--
I don't know about that--
but two, that we'll
get some information
from those deep structures
that you can't usually
see when you have just grids
sitting on the surface.
So back to functional MRI--
so this is primary
auditory cortex.
It's quite stylized.
Let me remind you where you are.
This is an inflated view
of the right hemisphere--
back of the head, front of the
head, temporal lobe, all funny
looking because it's been
mathematically unfolded
so you can see stuff in the
sulcus where I just showed you.
Primary auditory cortex
is in the sulcus.
But we've inflated
it so you can see it.
And so this is primary auditory
cortex, this whole thing here.
And it shows you a property
we've talked about before.
It's got a map, but the map
in primary auditory cortex
is not a map of space
like it is in the retina
for visual information.
It's a map of frequency.
And that makes sense
because the input transducer
is a cochlea, which
already physically creates
a map of frequency.
And so that gets
traveled through all
those intermediate stages
down in the basement,
and it comes up to
the brain, and makes
a map of frequency space.
So what this means,
actually-- so here's
sensitivity to
different frequencies.
And so the classic structure
of primary auditory cortex
in humans is high, low,
high-- high frequencies,
low frequencies,
high frequencies,
in that V-shaped pattern.
So this is the right hemisphere.
This is the left
hemisphere that's
been mirror flipped so you
can compare them directly.
And you can see this highly
stereotyped pattern of high,
low, high.
That's a tonotopic map.
Everybody clear on what
a tonotopic map is?
And we've just discretized
it into two chunks,
but it's actually a gradient
of high to low to high,
which you can kind of see
by those intermediate colors
in there.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] why
does the [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah,
everything in the brain
rearranges everything in
the input in multiple ways.
So we didn't talk about
this, but in visual cortex,
you have--
I don't know what the latest
count is, at least 10,
probably more than that,
separate retinotopic maps
in different patches of cortex--
map, map, map, map, loads
of them.
And so there's all kinds
of transformations.
And so much less is known about
the functional responses and
functional organization
of auditory cortex
than visual cortex, especially
in humans where we really
don't know a lot, in fact.
So there's no real
answer to that, other
than it's not that
shocking, in a way,
because you see that in
vision and in other domains
anyway, with multiple maps
that differentially represent
different parts of space.
And so yeah, I didn't
say this, but many
of those dozen or so
maps in visual cortex
have differential representation
of different parts of space.
Some focus on the
upper visual field,
some on the lower visual field.
And the whole question of
is that really one thing
or is it two--
this is all now
getting into the kind
of cutting-edge, ambiguous
state that we don't know.
All right, everybody clear
on tonotopy, primary auditory
cortex?
OK, good.
All right, the standard
view from recording neurons
in primary auditory
cortex in animals--
monkeys, ferrets are big
in auditory neuroscience,
other animals--
is that the receptive
fields of individual
neurons in primary
auditory cortex
are linear filters in
the following sense--
so here's a
spectrogram of a sound.
This is just a description
of the stimulus.
As usual, time, frequency.
So it looks like it could be a
speech sound with some vowels
there.
Or it might be something else.
Who knows.
So that's a sound.
So now, imagine an
electrode sitting
next to a single neuron
in primary auditory
cortex in, say, a ferret
listening to that sound,
and characterizing what
does that neuron respond to.
Well, the typical
finding is that neurons
in primary auditory
cortex are what's
known as spectral temporal
receptive fields, or STRFs
to their friends.
So what does that mean?
Here's an example of
the receptive field that
is the response dependence
of a given auditory cell,
again, with time on this axis
and frequency on that axis.
So what kind of sound
does that cell like?
Can you see just
by looking at this?
What kind of sound?
STUDENT: Increasing frequency.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Increasing frequency, yeah,
something like that right.
Here's one that also likes
increasing frequency,
but slower, shallower
increasing frequency.
Here's one that likes
decreasing frequency.
Now, you may be wondering
what the stripes are.
We didn't talk about
this in visual cortex,
but this is a common
property, that it
likes this particular
set of frequencies
here, but is inhibited
by adjacent frequencies.
So you also see something like
that with orientation tuning
in primary visual cortex.
And so here, these ones
are changing faster,
both increasing and decreasing.
So the idea is primary
auditory cortex in animals,
and presumably in humans,
is full of a bunch
of cells that are basically
spectrotemporal filters
like this.
They are picking out
changes in frequency
over time that happen
to different degrees,
and at different rates, and
in different frequency ranges.
Does that make
sense, more or less?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: I have a question.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] how would
you tell that was [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, how
do they figure that out?
I usually spend all this
time talking about the design
of the experiment.
I just skipped straight
to the answer here.
Well, I don't know exactly
what you do, but you probably--
I mean, this has
been a whole thing
that went on for decades
for people to get at this.
So I'm guessing
that somehow, they
got into that general
space, and then they
generated stimuli that make
all these different sounds.
And they just run
through them, and they
find, for a given cell, you
play all these different sounds.
You go-- [MAKES SOUNDS],,
et cetera.
I'll spare you more imitations.
You play all these different
sounds to the animal
and you record the
response of that neuron.
And you would find,
for example, that it
responds much more when you
play that sound than any
of the others.
Does that make sense?
STUDENT: No, it makes sense.
NANCY KANWISHER: But how
do they ever hit on that?
STUDENT: No, what
I was asking is
that are they using
separate [INAUDIBLE]??
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh,
the red and the blue?
How exactly they got-- rather
than just the simple thing with
just that--
how exactly they arrived on
that, I'm not totally sure.
I mean, there are mathematical
reasons why it makes sense
to have that whole thing rather
than just a single stripe,
that I think are
beyond the scope
of this lecture for the moment.
But anyway, it wasn't just a
totally arbitrary thing to try.
Those are particularly
useful kind
of receptive fields for
representing the input.
So everybody sort of
clear, approximately,
what this idea is?
So it's very
low-level basic, just
are the frequencies going
up or down, and which range,
and how fast?
That's what primary
auditory cortex
does organized in this
map, this tonotopic map.
So think of primary
auditory cortex as just
this bank, this big
set of linear filters
for particular frequency
changes over time.
So that's all based
on data from animals,
from recording
individual neurons.
But we want to know about
humans, not just because that's
what this course is about, but
we want to know about humans.
I mean, ferrets are
nice, but really!
So is that true for humans.
Well, Josh McDermott
and Sam Norman-Haignere
just published a
paper a few months ago
in which they
addressed this question
in a really interesting way.
So here's the logic-- this
is a little bit technical.
I'm trying to give you the gist.
I hope it works.
Give it a try.
So they generated
synthetically, computationally,
what they call
"model-matched stimuli."
So the idea is this--
the idea is if you
present a natural sound--
like a dog barking, or a person
speaking, or a toilet flushing,
just some sound that
you would hear in life--
and then what they do is they
make a synthetic signal that
matches that sound with
respect to those STRFs
I just showed you.
That is, if you fed
the original sound
and you fed this synthetic
sound into the STRFs,
you'd get the same
thing in the STRFs.
So this is a way
of saying, we're
assuming that those STRFs are
a good description of what
goes on in A1, so
let's test that
by taking a big, fancy,
real-world sound that
has meaning and
people know what it
is, and let's make
a control sound that
matches the in-STRF properties.
And let's see if we
get the same response
in the brain in that region.
If that model is
a good description
of what that region
does, then you
should get a very
similar response
when you give the synthetic
sound and the original sound
that you recorded in the world.
So they tested this
on a STRF-like model,
like this thing I
just described before.
And so just to show you
what these sounds are like--
so here's an original
sound just recorded
in the world of somebody typing.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, OK, OK, that's enough.
I know it's riveting,
but so then they run that
through their STRF model.
They get a STRF
description and they
generate a matched stimulus
from their STRF description.
And it sounds like this.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
Pretty good.
It's kind of hard
to tell them apart.
Sorry, enough.
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
And you can see
their spectrograms
are really similar.
So for a textury
thing like typing,
it really captures the
essence of what's being heard.
We're just telling you
what these control stimuli
sound like.
Let's take another sound,
a person walking in heels.
And you can see all
those verticals.
Those are the clicks.
Clicks have energy across
lots of different frequencies.
And that's what a
vertical line means--
it means all those
different-- remember,
this is frequency on this axis.
So a vertical line
means energy at lots
of different frequencies
not organized in harmonics,
so it's not pitchy.
Here we go.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[HEELS CLICKING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, here's the STRF version,
the control stimulus.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[CLICKING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So it captures some of
it, but not all of it.
It captures the
sound of each click,
but not the spacing between.
So it's getting the
local properties, but not
all of the properties.
Yeah.
STUDENT: How did you say--
like just the [INAUDIBLE]?
NANCY KANWISHER:
How do they make it?
I didn't tell you
because it's complicated.
They basically start with
pink noise, or white noise,
or some kind of noise.
They run it through
their STRF thing.
They run the original sound
through the STRF thing.
They compare them.
And they say, how are we
going to adjust the noise
to make it more like that?
And they just iterate a lot, and
they end up with these stimuli.
And you can see
just looking at it,
they ended up with
something that's
pretty similar in terms
of the spectrogram.
Let's listen to a
person speaking.
Here's the original sound.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Is that art offers a time
warp to the past, as well
as insight.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANCY KANWISHER: OK, now
I'm going to turn it off.
Here's the synthetic version.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, now we've lost something.
So does everybody see
how with keyboard typing,
it really sounds the same,
the synthetic version?
With walking in heels,
kind of, sort of,
at least locally, but not
globally, and with speech,
we've just totally lost it.
The stuff that you can
capture with a STRF model
does not capture the
full richness of speech.
There's something more
in a speech stimulus
than you can capture with
that just simple STRF model.
OK, let's listen to a violin.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, what does the STRF
model do with that?
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[MUDDY MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
I love that.
It sounds like a
sea lion colony.
Anyway, so what you see
is the STRF model totally
fails to capture
speech and music,
but it captures textury
sounds like that.
And it loses some of the broader
temporal scale information.
So that's the stimuli.
Then you scan people
listening to these sounds.
Just pop them in the scanner
and play those sounds.
And so then what they
do is they just ask.
So this is, again, the white
outline is primary auditory
cortex where you have
that frequency map, mapped
in a separate experiment, and
just plunk down on the brain
here.
We're zooming in on that part
of the top of the temporal lobe.
And so what's shown
here is, for each voxel,
they're showing the correlation
of the response of that voxel
to the original sound and
the synthetic, STRF-y sound.
And what you see is
those correlations
are really high in
primary auditory cortex.
In other words,
primary auditory cortex
responds pretty much the
same to the original sound
and the synthetic sound.
It doesn't detect
that difference.
But as soon as you get outside
of primary auditory cortex,
you get something
totally different.
And so that was
exactly the prediction,
is that model that's
being tested here
is a model of how they
thought primary auditory
cortex worked--
a bank of linear filters.
They test that model by
generating a new set of stimuli
that are matched for
those linear filters,
and they get pretty
much the same response
in primary auditory cortex.
So check-- that's a good model
of primary auditory cortex.
But also, the blue
shows you much lower
correlation out here.
It is not a good model of stuff
outside of auditory cortex.
Josh.
STUDENT: So isn't this
kind of self-fulfilling,
in the sense that I build
my synthetic stimuli based
on these kind of
models, and then--
NANCY KANWISHER: It is,
except the models were all
based on animal work and
this is human brains.
So this is a way--
but that's exactly right.
It's a way of saying all this
work from animals precisely
characterizing
response properties
of individual neurons, which
you can do in animals and mostly
not in humans, do
we think that's
true of human primary
auditory cortex?
And yes, it is.
Does everybody get at
least the gist of that?
I realize I skipped
over lots of details
because I want you to
get the general picture.
Yeah.
STUDENT: What are they
trying to achieve by doing
this type of [INAUDIBLE]?
I mean, the hypothesis
is that the human
and the animal auditory
cortex is the same?
NANCY KANWISHER: Primary
auditory cortex, yes.
Yes.
They're basically testing--
you derive that model
from the animal work, then
you design a test of it,
which is making those
synthetic stimuli.
And I left this out
because actually, I
don't think they've done
that, but presumably,
if you test those stimuli
with single units in ferrets,
you get the same thing.
You get very, very
similar responses
in primary auditory cortex
to the original sound
and the synthetic version of
it based on the STRF model.
STUDENT: It's predicated on the
assumption that both of them
are structurally the same.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Well, it's testing.
It's asking that question.
Because I've occasionally in
here lamented about how crappy
our methods are in human
cognitive neuroscience.
I mean, they're fun.
We can do something, but
we hit a wall pretty fast.
We want to see the
actual neural code.
We don't have spatial
and temporal resolution
at the same time.
We pretty much only
get that in animals.
We can pretty much only do
really careful causal tests
in animals.
We can pretty much only see
connectivity in a precise way.
And all these things we
can do only in animals.
And so we need to know if
those animal models are
good models for humans.
And this is a way to test it.
And it passed with
flying colors.
Make sense?
So primary auditory
cortex seems in humans
that it's much like
it is in ferrets,
a bank of linear filters
with STRF-y properties.
What about everything else?
After all, you guys
can hear the difference
between the original version
and the synthetic version
of the woman talking
and the violin.
And if I played you
all the other stimuli
of real-world sounds, you
could hear the differences
in many of the
other ones as well.
So what are you doing?
Well, there's lots
of auditory cortex
beyond primary auditory
cortex that could
represent that difference.
And what this is
suggesting is, whatever's
going on out here is doing
something really different
with those sounds.
It is not fooled.
It does not think the synthetic
thing is the same thing
as the original thing.
That's what the low
correlation means.
So I'll tell you about just
one little patch of cortex
out there.
And that is-- again, this
is just for reference.
We've zoomed in again on
this is the little code
for separate mapping of high,
low, high, primary auditory
cortex right there.
And what the yellow bands are is
selective responses to speech.
So you compare a
whole bunch of speech
sounds to a whole bunch
of non-speech sounds,
and you get a band
of activation right
below primary auditory cortex.
Yes.
STUDENT: I thought the
separation was low, high,
medium [INAUDIBLE].
NANCY KANWISHER:
High, low, high--
I probably said it backwards.
That would be like me.
But it's-- wait, wait.
What the hell is it?
I'm pretty sure it's
high, low, high.
Let's go back and look.
I might have screwed it up on
the slide or said it backwards,
but I'm pretty sure
it's high, low, high.
STUDENT: So the low
frequency is the [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, just like
that's the code for frequency,
right there.
But ask me those
questions because I'm
very capable of getting things
backwards, as you've probably
already noticed.
So there is a band of
speech-selective cortex just
outside of primary
auditory cortex,
in that region that we just
saw responds differently
to the original sound and the
model-matched synthetic sound.
So that's pretty cool.
What do I mean by
"speech-selective cortex?"
What I mean is--
this is some of our data.
I tried to find you
someone else's data
and I went down a
45-minute rabbit hole
trying to find a nice slide.
And I just couldn't
find a good picture.
I finally said, screw it,
I'll show you my data,
even though I'm trying to--
we're not the only
ones who've shown this.
We just have the best data.
Other people had tested it with
four, five, six conditions.
We tested it with 165 sounds.
So this is the
magnitude of response
in that yellow region to 165
different sounds, color coded
by condition shown down here.
And so what you see
if you look at it
is all the top sounds are
light green and dark green.
Speech-- notice, importantly,
that the response
is very similar to English
speech and foreign speech
which our subjects
do not understand.
So that tells us that this
is not about language.
This is not about the meaning
of a sentence, or syntax, or any
of that stuff.
This is about phonemes,
the difference
between a ba and a pa, which you
can do on a foreign language,
even if there's a few
phonemes that are different.
You get most of them.
Does everybody
get the difference
between speech and language?
Amazingly, the senior
author of the paper
you read for last night does
not understand that difference.
He published a beautiful paper.
Every time he comes
here to speak,
he talks about language,
language, language, language.
And I say, Eddie, have you ever
presented a stimulus that's
in a foreign language?
He's, like, oh, no, that'd
be really interesting.
It's like, Eddie, until you do
that, you don't know if you're
studying language or speech.
Oh, yeah, really interesting.
And then he comes
back four years later
and he doesn't seem to know
the difference between language
and speech.
I'm, like, hello.
Anyway, he does beautiful
experiments, but it's just--
it's a blind spot, or
it's a misuse of a word.
I don't know what it is,
but it drives me nuts.
Can you tell?
Anyway, you guys get that
difference even if Eddie
doesn't.
Let's look at some other things.
How about all this
light blue stuff?
There's a lot of light blue
stuff that's almost as high.
Oh, that's music
with people singing.
That also has speech.
The speech is slightly
less intelligible
because it's
singing, and there's
background instrumental music,
so it's a little bit lower.
Oh, what's next?
We've got some
light purple stuff
and some dark purple stuff.
This is non-speech
vocalizations.
That's stuff like laughing,
and crying, and sighing--
pretty similar to
speech but not speech.
It's the next highest
thing, but it's well down
from the speech sounds.
And then we have dogs
barking, and geese,
and stuff like that, that
are yet further down.
And then we have all kinds
of other stuff down there--
sirens, and toilets,
and stuff like that.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Is instrumental
music perceived as speech?
I mean, I can't
make out the colors.
NANCY KANWISHER: No.
The instrumental music
is way down in here.
Yeah, it's a little hard to see.
That stuff up there is
non-speech vocalizations.
It's not a perfect slide.
So that's pretty strong evidence
that that band of cortex
is pretty selective for speech.
Everybody get that?
Yeah.
STUDENT: So you're
saying it's not
like it doesn't process
like the other one,
so the violin stuff would
still be that [INAUDIBLE]
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, right.
OK, good point.
Remember when I first showed
you the fusiform face area,
I showed you that time where
it's faces are like this,
staring at dot is like
that, looking at objects
is like this.
So I said, OK, there's a little
bit of a response to things
that aren't faces.
It's just much more to faces.
Now, you guys may
not have noticed this
because it went by kind of
fast, but when I showed you
intracranial data
from the fusiform face
area in that patient who
got stimulated there,
and saw the illusory faces,
the intracranial data
showed zero response to
things that are not faces.
So I think that that's
because functional MRI is
the best we have in spatial
resolution in the human brain,
except when we have
intracranial data.
But it's still blurry.
It's blurry because there's
blood flow and all of that.
So I would guess
the same thing here.
In fact, I guess it
isn't in the paper you
read because he didn't
have any non-speech sounds,
but I will show you.
Dana's recording them right
now at Children's Hospital,
and we have some other ones
that I will show you next time,
of intracranial electrodes.
And they will be even
more selective than that.
But this is pretty good already.
Yeah, Nava.
STUDENT: What's the
human non-vocal?
NANCY KANWISHER: I didn't hear.
What?
STUDENT: The human non-vocal?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, that's
like clapping, and footsteps,
and I forget what else, things
where you hear it and you know
that's a person, but
it doesn't sound at all
like speaking or speech.
So if it was about
the meaning, it
could have been all about
the meaning of people,
could be something telling
you there's a person there.
Deal with it.
But no, apparently not.
So we're not the first
ones to see this.
We've just tested it
with more conditions.
So our evidence for selectivity
is stronger than everyone
else's.
Given what I've told you today,
can you think of a stronger way
to test this?
For example, suppose
I was worried,
maybe the frequency
composition of the speech
is different than
the non-speech.
After all, those
are just recordings
of natural sounds in the world
that we went out and made,
or mostly got off the
web, someone else made.
And maybe they differ in
really low-level properties.
And so how do we know
that that's really
speech selectivity,
not just selectivity
for certain frequencies
or frequency changes?
Yes.
STUDENT: You could run it
with the McDermott generate--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Bingo, absolutely.
Everybody get that?
So then we'd know, because
those are beautifully
designed to match all
those acoustic properties,
match the spectrogram for all
those lower level properties.
And McDermott and
Norman-Haigenere
have done that.
And this region does
not respond strongly
to the model-matched
version, so it's not
just the acoustic properties.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Can we also do
something like [INAUDIBLE] play
speech backwards?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes,
people have done that, too.
It's a little bit complicated,
because speech backward
sounds a lot like speech.
It's kind of in the
intermediate zone.
So it balances many
things, but one, it
doesn't balance all the
acoustic properties.
So speech has certain
onset properties.
I forget how it goes, but
if you play it backwards,
there's lots of--
[MAKING SOUNDS] You've heard
backward speech played, right?
And so the STRF model
would respond differently
to forward and backward speech,
whereas the STRF model responds
the same to the original
and the synthetic speech.
Make sense?
So there's a very
speech-selective patch
of cortex.
And it's speech selective,
not language selective.
And of course, we want to know--
speech is lots of
different things.
It's what words you're saying.
It's who's saying it.
It's your intonation--
are you making
a statement, or a
question, or what
are you emphasizing
in the sentence?
And it's lots of other things.
And the paper you read
asked that question.
What's coded here about speech?
And so I made a
whole bunch of slides
to explain what the paper
said because I thought people
would have trouble with it.
And everyone nailed
it, so I'm not even
going to go through them.
Maybe I'll just
show one in closing.
So one thing a few
of you got wrong--
and I totally get why,
it didn't matter--
is that here is
this is one patient,
and this is the bank
of electrodes placed
on the surface of the brain.
The red bits are
the bits where you
could account for the
neural responses in terms
of any of those models--
intonation, speaker
identity, sentence,
or any of the interactions
between those things.
And so that just says
that's where the action is,
is those electrodes there.
And that graph down here is
from only three different--
each one is a single electrode,
just so you get this.
So this critical graph here,
that shows electrode E1.
That's one of those
electrodes in one patient.
An electrode is typically
2 millimeters on a side.
It's probably listening to a few
tens of thousands of neurons.
So it's one or two
orders of magnitude
better than a voxel
with functional MRI,
but it's still
averaging over lots
of neurons, not a single nerve.
STUDENT: The
question [INAUDIBLE]
averaging over [INAUDIBLE] but
it's averaged over [INAUDIBLE]..
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah, that was
the response of one electrode
listening to male and female.
I forget which is which.
But other than that, you
guys totally nailed it.
And notice how precise, and
specific, and fascinatingly
separated the responses
of those electrodes
are, segregated for pitch
contour, or speaker identity,
or what sentence
was being spoken.
Those things seem to
be segregated spatially
in the brain at a fine grain.
Whether you'd see it
with functional MRI--
you might, might not.
Many of you pointed out we might
have not have the resolution.
Think about other
methods you might
use to look for that, even if
we didn't have the resolution
with a simple binary contrast.
And it's 12:26 and
I'm going to stop.
I will see you
guys on Wednesday,
and we will talk about music.